c'est leur première réunion publique le
collectif réinventons et l'encours s'est
rassemblée ce samedi un collectif
composé d'une quinzaine de personnes qui
entend instaurer le débat avec la
population
c'est surtout la méthode qui me semble
tout à fait arrêté intéressante à savoir
qu' on veut faire émerger dans
l'ensemble des citoyens et bien un
projet de ville voilà une orientation
générale des méthodes et des contenus
qu'ils soient à l'image des habitants
si la tête de liste n'a pas encore été
désignés les organisateurs de cette
réunion revendique déjà un programme
défendant des valeurs de gauche
moi effectivement je suis membre de
génération mais quelques-uns gelé dit en
introduction il ya des militants qui
sont engagés au pca génération certains
au ps il ya aussi des gens qui sont
plutôt engagés dans les associations de
la ville et puis des gens qui sont pas
forcément comparé forcément d'engagement
en tout cas jusqu'ici
donc c'est vraiment une liste assez
varié donc pour l'instant on n'a pas y'a
pas de label pausé maire sortant les
républicains et président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
à lui déjà officialisé sa candidature
pour mars 2020